Hey sir swing it good
it will kill
the ultimate forged and fired matchup
the forest and fire Champion two
Champion planes in a deadly weapon
showed it will kill 20 blades 20
Champions you decide the winner forged
in fire Madness
George Washington's coalish mark
my name is Josh Nicholas the reason why
I started blade smithing is because I
was practicing a lot of survival skills
and all the scoreboard knives that I had
just turned out to be junk so I heard I
can make my own my friends would
describe me as the goofy rednecked now
bro I would describe me as the goofy
redneck down the road nikoli schmored
was a unique dueling sword that became
popular during the late 17th century and
was a favorite blade style of George
Washington the weapon had an extremely
broad Forte which gave the blade ample
parrying strength however the sword
rapidly tapered to a thin Point allowing
for precise thrusting and stabbing
attacks an avid sword collector George
Washington even had a kalish mark bladed
small sword at his side while swearing
in as America's first president the
weapon was such an iconic part of
Washington's Persona one can even be
spotted alongside the first president in
this iconic 1824 John Trumbull painting
Napoleon's saber
my name is Seth lorries I'm 30 years old
and I'm from Gautier Mississippi I would
consider myself a bayou boy because
that's all there is is by using Gautier
winning this competition would mean a
great stepping stone to further in my
dream of becoming a full-time bladesmith
one of history's most ingenious military
Minds Napoleon Bonaparte was France's
Emperor beginning in the early 1800s
Napoleon revolutionized Battlefield
tactics with the brilliant use of
cannonade in close coordination with
Cavalry his Lightning Fast Horseman
carried pistols and curved Savers which
delivered deadly thrusts and crippling
slashes in close combat in the pivotal
Battle of Morengo a victory that assured
his political ascendance in France
Napoleon carried this gold adorned saber
feels real good to be back on in my
normal shop get my thinking cap on my
biggest concern is figuring out the
trifoil blade is definitely the most
intricate sword I've ever made but I'm
confident that I can redneck engineer it
I'm about four inches into putting this
tri-fold in there and I realized that
instead of wavering off back and forth I
need to just cut a small groove on the
line where I need to go to help keep it
where it needs to be
so now that I have a guideline cut
trifold's coming along more in straight
line like it needs to be so far things
are going about 98 the way I intended
for him to go
I am extremely happy that the blade is
done
so I can focus on the guard assembly the
handle and the palm so for the palm oil
I'm actually using a piece of muzzle
loader rifle barrel
for the handle I'm going to use a bingo
which is like a tropical hardwood but
it's super light do a little work there
too
you told me at the end of day two that I
was going to be where I'm at now I
wouldn't believe you
day four
I'm back home at my home Forge in
Gautier Mississippi and I'm going to be
working on Napoleon saber I decided to
go with 5160. it is a great Spring Steel
but I'm looking at the blade and I think
I have a little too much curvature I was
at the three inch Mark so I had to put
it back in the Forge and knock it down
I knocked it down a little too far
time to go back in the Forge again it's
kind of like a cat and mouse game
it's a little over an inch
well it's just one of those things
it's back and forth and back and forth
and I'm finally
got it it's time to move on to the heat
treatment of the blade the idea is is to
get as a even heat on this as uh
possible
and like Napoleon I will divide and
conquer
I don't feel no ticks I don't feel no
Tings
I have a hardened blade
it's time to do a rough fit up of the
wood part of the handle and the pommel I
look down at the floor and I'm looking
at the deer antlers that I have and I
noticed the curvature in them no one
says that it has to be made out of brass
copper or gold as long as I Hollow it
out and it has a nice taper to it and it
fits the hand why not a deer antler
you gotta fit
the closer and closer I get towards the
final shape of it I'm feeling it in my
hand kind of twirling it a little bit
not quite as good as Doug Marcato will
be doing but feels good in the hand
becoming a forge and fire Champion would
be a great way to show people that I can
do this and would be one step closer for
me to becoming a full-time bladesmith
because this is the the dream right here
I am
done I couldn't be happier
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do I will take care and
deliver harassing cuts and thrusts to
this big carcass Joshua first you ready
not really but go ahead
[Music]
thank you
all right Josh first up it's got nice
weight to it now your handle
construction it is small enough to where
I can get my hand around it but it
doesn't roll your Edge as you can see is
sharp it will kill nicer Seth you ready
for this let's do it
foreign
[Music]
to the Trotter every cut with this as
you can see offers a very deep
lacerating cut the only issue is that
your blade did pick up a little bit of a
Bend but overall Sir with the way this
weapon moves and feels it will kill
thank you very much good job it's time
for the strength test our cherry wood
chop
in honor of George Washington
the cosmar was known as a fast light
flexible weapon it was designed for the
duel so to test the strength of your
blade I'll be doing several tip Cuts
against that wood and then thrusting
into it flexing your blade in both
directions make sure that temper is
right and that that blade doesn't pick
up a set Josh you're up first you ready
go for it
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
thank you
all right Josh there are a lot of pointy
bits on this guard that don't need to be
there that really
digs right into your hand other than
that did well it flexed very nicely and
came back to true so good job thank you
little blade Smiths a saber's supposed
to be a sturdy weapon so let's see how
yours hold up on our strength test the
ram skull chop
now I'm going to take each of your
Sabers and with no mercy it all bash
them into those ram skull
it's not only going to test the overall
strength of your knife but to heat treat
on your Edge now I don't really care
what your swords do to the skulls I want
to see what the skulls do to your swords
now Seth Europe you ready to go swing it
good
ah
all right Seth your Edge held up but we
do have a bigger Bend in the blade than
we had before your guard is now mobile
and both of your bolsters came off as
well so this mechanical connection right
in here failed but the connection
between your blade and your handle is
still sturdy
you took some damage but you survived
good job thank you sir now it's your
turn which weapon will you choose forged
and fire Madness